why are you so mad for golly I'm a girl
I'm just a photographer thing yeah why
are you so rude just hit in the window
but why are you hitting the window
because people on the street I'm a
photographer I'm looking for celebrities
I thought you're a celebrity you got
some I think you're drunk I can smell
your alcohol over here
but why are you being so mean
yeah
thank you
what's going on Nick
why are you swinging a girl's phone bro
why are you swinging at girls bro why
are you
should be ashamed of yourself Nick
so if you can see your name and spell it
for me please my name's Jody j-o-d-y and
Jody what do you do for a job I'm a
celebrity photographer so what happens
tonight in Beverly Hills well I was
driving down Cannon and I looked over at
Mastro's Restaurant and I saw Nick
Lachey and his wife standing out front
so I rode my window down grabbed my
camera turn my flash on I started to
take pictures he got really upset and
came running over and he as he was
running over I rolled my window up
because I got scared and he punched my
window almost broke it and then he
started to walk away and I rolled my
window down and I grabbed my cell phone
and started filming him and I said why
did you try to punch my window what's
going on and then he made a big Ruckus
and I presumed he was drunk because he's
really acting weird and stuff I did
smell alcohol and I even told him I said
are you drunk I could smell alcohol and
he he was drunk
and then and then what happened after
that and then after that then he took
off back to the restaurant and then him
and his wife went walking all the way
down an alley like down towards Wilshire
but he was flipping off and he was like
going carrying on and like you know
cussing at me and cussing at another
photographer that was there and
it's crazy you already have been shaken
up but I'm totally shaken up I can't
believe it I thought he was a nice guy
because he used to be a nice guy but he
did that and it was like really crazy I
couldn't believe it it's like insane
you know I'm shaking up it's like it's
really stupid that he would do that type
of thing to a female I I even said why
are you trying to hit a girl I'm a
girl's photographer and he just went on
and on and he he was really whacked out
I was mine it seemed it sounds like it's
really uncalled for yes